[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is zarita and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
benefits of volunteering during high
school
years High School is a transformative
period in a young person's life it's a
Time marked by academic hurdles social
adventures and the journey of
self-discovery it can be a very hard
phase for teenagers as they come across
many obstacles in different aspects of
life but what if I told you that adding
volunteering to the mix can have a
profound impact on your life and the
lives of those around you well that's
what we're here to discuss today let's
start by exploring the first key benefit
which is personal
growth High School is not just about
textbooks and exams it's also about
personal growth is the stage in life
when most people start to form and build
their
personalities volunteering provides a
unique opportunity for young individuals
to develop essential life skills from
leadership and communication to time
management and problem solving
volunteering can help shape responsible
confident and well-rounded individuals
it helps them become better in more ways
than just
academically now let's shine a spotlight
on Community Connection in high school
it's easy to get caught in a small world
but volunteering can expand your
horizons it's an effective tool that can
help you build connections with the
people in your community providing
access to a wide range of viewpoints and
life experiences thereby breaking
through the limitations of a restricted
Viewpoint engaging in volunteer
activities provide students with a
remarkable chance to delve deeply into
the inner workings of their communities
and learn about the Urgent needs and
issues that frequently go unnoticed in
day-to-day Life as a result this
approach creates a greater feeling of
empathy and a sense of shared
accountability for for the welfare of
their fellow community members it is
impossible to ignore the potential for
positive change that resides within each
and every one of us when you see the
apparent outcomes that may be achieved
by devoting your time and effort to
those in need it Sparks a passion and
develops an undying dedication to the
goal of helping one's
community in this way volunteering
develops into a meaningful and
transforming experience a journey that
can dramatically affect a person's
entire life in addition to their high
school years giving them a sense of
purpose and a lifetime commitment to
improving
Society furthermore another benefit that
volunteering offers is social skills and
friendships High School is also about
forming relationships that last
volunteering provides a unique social
platform where you can connect with
peers who are equally committed to
giving back this way you get to
socialize and expand beyond your comfort
zone volunteering exposes students to
diverse cultures backgrounds and
perspectives it helps promote cultural
sensitivity and a broader worldview the
bonds that develop through collaborative
community service often becomes some of
the strongest relationships you'll ever
cherish as it's one of the best ways of
finding people who you share similar
interests with these bonds are born out
of shared experiences values and goals
making them some of the most treasured
relationships one can cultivate during
the formative years these relationships
not only enhance the high school
experience but also endure throughout
one's lifetime demonstrating the
significant and long- lasting effects of
volunteering on Social Development and
the forming of lifelong
friendships next up we have academic
benefits contrary to the belief that
volunteering distracts from academic
success it often enhances it many
colleges and universities highly value
volunteer experience I personally know
people who were able to get into their
dream universities with the help of an
excellent CV which included previous
volunteer work this demonstrates your
commitment to making a difference and
can give you an edge in the competitive
world of higher
education plus it's an opportunity to
explore potential care career paths and
gain insights you won't find in a
classroom furthermore moving on to a
more practical aspect which is resume
building as you transition into
adulthood your resume serves as your
symbolic introduction to the
professional World High School
volunteering proves to be incredibly
beneficial in this regard it catches the
attention of employers and scholarship
committees showing them that you're a
well-rounded individual who is dedicated
to making a positive impact
in a highly competitive job or college
application process volunteering can set
you apart from other candidates who may
have similar academic qualifications
ultimately increasing your chances of
securing financial aid or employment
opportunities and lastly let's talk
about personal
fulfillment when you volunteer you feel
great because you know you're making a
positive impact on other other people's
lives even in small ways
this feeling can be like a Guiding Light
in your life research has shown that
volunteering makes people happier and
less stressed but the benefits of
volunteering go beyond just feeling good
it also helps you learn more about
yourself and the world around you you
can discover new talents become more
empathetic and gain important life
skills when you work with different
communities and face various challenges
as a young volunteer you get a better
understanding of society and how you can
help make it better moreover
volunteering in high school not only
gives you a sense of purpose and
happiness but also broadens your
perspective on life it makes you more
aware of your role in society and helps
you build lasting connections with your
local and Global
communities in a world where finding
fulfillment can be hard High School
volunteering can be a path to
self-discovery active involvement in
society and long- Lasting happiness to
sum it up volunteering during High
School is an investment in personal
growth Community Connection academic
success Social Development resume
enhancement and personal fulfillment
it's a journey that extends beyond your
school years shaping you into a
responsible compassionate and
multi-talented individual who's ready to
make a
difference thank you so much for joining
us on this episode of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take
[Music]
care